欢迎收听古爱,微信木工本期节目由Sally赞助
不知不觉一年过了快一半,时间真的是过很快
最近不早人开始在看端午年假要去哪里玩
甚至有些人行程都排好了
简单说就是人还在公司,但脑子已经在机场
这种时候会发生一件固定的事
出国需求开始上来,然后同一个老问题一起回归
网路
很多人行程排得很满,机票、饭店、景点都研究得很细
但最容易出事情的是最基本的网路
到当地的才发现没有网路
导航卡住,轿车失败,餐厅找不到
整趟旅行便求生模式
现在比较省事的方法是eSIM
像Sally的eSIM
出国前先设定好
落地直接连线
不用换卡
不用找针
也不用在机场翻行李
流量可以在APP里面直接看
用完再加就好
不用整张重来
再加上VPN广告阻挡
基本上把出国最容易遇到的那一段
全部处理掉
比较新的变化是iOS26
也开始支援原生eSIM自动切换
出国时会自动启用旅游方案
回国再切回本地的门号
整体又再少了一步的操作
如果說你六月已經在看機票
那網路這件事情可以先把它處理好
先下載Seddy App
輸入優惠代碼 GOOAYE
或是透過資訊欄的連結
seddy.com slash GOOAYE
向85折的優惠
在這邊聽說給所有需要的朋友們
那參加完今年的Computex
覺得是收穫非常多啦
我覺得今年的展會
可能是我在過去的
兩三年最喜歡的一場
那當然今年的展會
在網路上也有很多討論
你要知道其實每個東西
都一定丟出來
會有正方跟反方的一些意見
那一般反方的意見
都會被放到很大
然後大家就會覺得說
是不是可能不太好啊
或什麼的
然後就一堆人開始出來hater
出來幹狗什麼有的沒有的
那像比較常看到一些討論在講說
什麼像Combutex已經不純粹了
已經不是什麼廠商去那邊
什麼換名片了
是一堆什麼死老百姓也會跑進去
然後再來就是有人講說
有一些什麼追星仔也會跑進去
他根本就不懂產業或什麼的
其實我覺得這是好事情
就是當然可能對裡面一些
去做demo的人來說
他會覺得說他會有蠻多的無效嘗試
我跟一個死老百姓解釋了半天
你也不會買我們的東西
那我幹嘛跟你解釋
可是某個程度上就是出圈的意志
就像是我的節目
因為希望說從頭到尾都跟大家講一些
我們真的在市場裡面做的東西
可是為什麼我每次講到周面
我都會跟大家講說
好啦你們還不懂得先去買指數
因為我知道我的節目很多死老百姓
因為我們就出圈了
出圈的時候就是會有一些
怎麼講就是說
他並不是可能對這個東西
研究很深的人來聽
他聽你的做法他去做
他真的可能會BBQ他會爆炸
就像有一個大媽
如果他真的跟你講說
Servor Rack給我來一 rack
他真的有他媽一億
他會跟你買的話
你賣他嗎你就很怪嗎
所以你會跟他講說
你還是去買隔壁的RTX Spark就好了
就是有點類似那樣子的感覺沒有辦法人多了之後就一定會有這樣子一個情形我覺得其實對於第一線的人員他們可能會很幹掉因為覺得說花很多時間去做無效溝通可是對老闆來講大家一定是很開心的
因為這麼多人來參與
那其實是讓整個膚況度變得更高
那有些生意是這樣子
他不一定是在當下感覺是有辦法接到
因為可能是一個大媽一個阿姨
或是一個小弟什麼高中上來聽
可是你不知道他背後爸爸是誰
搞不好回去跟爸爸說
爸爸我覺得這很酷
然後他們就直接在他們的公司
建一個Enterprise Server之類的
所以很難說啦
我覺得就這樣不要去
怎麼講 以偏概全或是以貿取人
看到人家怎麼樣
然後說一堆死老百姓來看展
或什麼不純粹的或撒小
不知道我覺得這是一個很怪的討論
當然有些人講的像什麼
一堆追星族
我是只會覺得說人太多
可能會有一些煩躁
但也不會真的覺得討厭
因為黃文勳他就真的變Superstar
一個白髮阿伯
然後走在台北的路上
每個人跟追韓國什麼
我現在如果講韓團
大家都知道我年紀很大
我只想得到Super Junior
我不知道他媽最新的是誰
反正就像是這樣
大家看到這個白髮杯就high了
高潮噴水要看他什麼的
所以你沒有辦法
他在這個地方會出行
當然就會有一堆他的追星族來
甚至是你到現場去看
你會覺得整個Computex
當然我主要是聚焦在一管四樓的部分
好像說是黃人群的塗鴉牆一樣
你走到哪都會看到他的簽名
真的是走到哪都是仁勳哥爾的簽名
當然有些簽名不一定是說
他今年走到哪就是故意要
這個地方要留下一點痕跡之類
可能是去年的大家把一樣的背板
或者說曾經被他簽過的產品拿出來
但你真的走到哪就發現說
其實Computex get slash
這個是人勳展
就你走到哪都是人勳的東西
有些人也對這個很感冒
就是說是怎樣
怎麼全部來追行
但我覺得大家要放寬心
這個東西走出來讓大家明白
同時越來越多
感覺是不相關的人介入
就代表說其實你這個東西是紅了
你已經不是圈內自己人在玩了
他也會額外再產生很多機會
大概這樣
可能就是第一線去做解釋的人
會稍微的煩躁一點
但老闆們我相信是非常開心的
我對於這次的展會我也是覺得是開心的
因為看到了蠻多
我認為跟過去的一兩年比起來
怎麼講我自己是很相信未來科技的人
我也相信說科技可以產生很多很酷很新的變化
可是當整天都在跟我打高空的時候
我自己會雷達大響
我就覺得很奇怪
你怎麼在跟我講一些未來怎麼樣
我很討厭聽到人家開口幣
我就未來未來未來這樣
你直接告訴我說現在可以做什麼
因為如果現在可以做的東西
就像說類似我們玩手遊
你知道嗎
那個卡片有時候你多抽幾張那你點到加3之後它就直變什麼叫直變它可能CD少兩回合之類光這樣子就會造成非常巨大的一個改變所以其實你只需要把你的生產力持續的往上點
點到某個地方就會開支善業
就會產生很多新的應用跟可能性
你不用坐在那邊跟大家說
我們想想一個未來是什麼樣
因為我覺得那個是很好笑的
你在AI的第一年這樣做可以
可是在第二年第三年
像之前還是會看到很多的什麼機械狗
或是很多不明所以然的AI應用
就會覺得搞不好真的有泡泡存在的可能性
會不會真的後面要泡沫化之類的
但像今年的話就不會給你這樣子的一個感受
今年看下來每個東西都是超級實際的
而且是真的會讓你看完就說
Shut up take my money
就是我要直接跟你買下來太帥了
首先非常感謝邀我去看展的各路好朋友們
其實是真的非常多人都會來邀展
只是小弟沒有這麼多的時間
所以我就是去找可能當年最早找我的這些人
那我就是每年都是跟他們的
所以非常感謝像是NVIDIA的小金
然後非常感謝ASUS ROG的Mickey
然後還有像MediaTag的Jennifer
那他以前是在Adventag
那時候也是透過他去看東西
然後因為他現在跑到MediaTag
他又找我去我就跟著去看
然後在MediaTag的攤位上
我不知道有這麼多的地方聽眾
各位大哥大姐們
非常感謝跟小弟解釋這麼多東西
那所以就是抓這些重點
去把它稍微看一下
跟大家分享自己的心得
首先一大早
我們是先跑到NV Enterprise
它是辦在TICC
其實NV他們現在是很有想法
因為東西可能太多要展
所以他們都會去搞自己的施展
在TICC這個你是憑證就可以一起去看
如果是在漢萊的消費的話
你是沒有辦法去憑證
你要透過可能有官方人員邀請你的話
那就可以去看
我兩個都有跑去
那先講一下Enterprise的心得
其實Enterprise整體來說
跟過去幾年是差不多的
今年我們想看的一些重點是
就來說像PowerRack有沒有一些展出
因為已經有看到一些朋友去拍
那個超級電容超大一顆的
難怪可以一顆賣到
可能以前的ASP的快100倍這樣子
因為它的尺寸也是大了大概5倍左右
然後再來就是可能會想看
LPU上面有沒有什麼一些新的
可能Gadget在上面
是我們過去沒有注意到的
或是一些光通的東西
那我注意到今年有蠻多的東西
它是把它封起來
像LPU的話你就只看得到
就是黑媽媽的一片管線
散熱板或什麼的
那它裡面的東西就全部都擋起來
沒有辦法看到
當然我們還是有辦法透過一些管道
其實我們知道說裡面的東西是怎麼樣
只是它可能還沒有ready
所以就長這個樣子
LPU大家會比較期待的原因新聞它並不會說真的放到極大的一個量它大概我們目前估計一年來說大概就是1萬到可能1萬5千Racks左右可是畢竟它是一個新的東西
它是完成收購之後所搞出來的一個新的路線
所以我們會很好奇它裡面有什麼樣的一些元件
但就是比較可惜沒有看到
再來有看到CPU Rack
CPU Rack的話其實大家都算是非常的熟悉
反正CPU的Configuration大家都已經懂了
只是它現在把它變成是Hole Rack去做推出
最主要的應用就是用在Agentic的AI Workflow裡面
其實在這邊市場上有一個說法是這樣子
之所以會用到這麼多的CPU
其實是因為現在Agentic Workflow並沒有做得很好
所以模型很多時候它是在撞牆
它瘋狂的撞牆要去找那個路線
所以導致它去用掉了很多的CPU
等到有一天可能把模型優化之後
說不定就不需要用到這麼多的CPU了
就有些人會用一些可能比較偏空的角度來看這件事情
這件事情我覺得還是回到Satia講的那個
反正總之就是你把一個東西的成本降低
大家可能會以為說
OK所以這些元件就沒有辦法再炒上去了
需求就沒有這麼大
沒有你把它成本降低
其實用的人會更多
像他在用AI的人
嚴格上來說是很小百分比的人
一些那種什麼geek在用
實際上在大家生活之中
每個人都會講AI
可是你說他們到底exposure多少
那個很不多
所以我不會認為說
你去把軟體的一些流程給改善之後
你就會少用CPU
對你會少用一點CPU as a person
但是會有更多人用
你會有更多的應用都要去用
所以整體來說那個數字會再更大
所以像CPU zone configuration
就是在後面還是可以持續的去做關注
因為在Agentic的Wolfflow裡面
他必須要整天的去支用各式各樣的東西
去做派遣
有一個像是教練的形式的存在
所以在CPU的用量就會去走到很大
再往後看的話
關於像是Viarubin
大家都非常熟悉
所以我們就不用再花太多時間去講
但有時候我會覺得有點不公平
因為可能有人是剛加入市場的
他就會想說這個對他來說是新鮮的東西
然後我們一直講說這個是老梗
這個可能有點類似說
搞不好我們在可能
因為我最早看台積電的時候
大概他是一兩百塊的東西
我在看一兩百塊的台積電
我覺得是很新鮮很酷的東西的時候
我後來只好說像我們樓下的一個鄰居
他是幾十塊的時候就在看台積電的
因為他就是年紀比較大一點
所以在他的角度說不定
那時候我就跟他討論的時候
他又講說這個東西可以到那麼高嗎
就是我以前看他是十幾塊
他現在兩百多塊
你說可以到一千
我不太相信可以到1000
可是最後沒有
他可能真的到12000 3000去
所以後來的人
當然這些東西對他們來講
還是很新鮮的
只是說對於前面的人來說
有時候我們自己要做
注意說不要被矛定的
因為我們可能已經很習慣說
像以前這些OEM ODM EMS
或是機能代工業者
他是多少錢
EPS多少
他也曾經推出了什麼產品
這我們都聽到膩了
不要再聽了
可是如果你有這樣子的想法的話
你可能會錯過後面的一些漲幅
因為他可能好就還會再來更好
這個是我們自己會想要小心的
反正總之就是去看的
像是Viarubin或是
Grace Blackwell的相關的設計
這個對我講已經是很熟悉的
當然也聊到比較聊
我們就不用再聊
我們稍微的看了一下Kyber
Kyber的東西其實也是跟去年差不多
現在看到Switch Blade是超大一片
這個可能是我記得好像去年印象中
是沒有看到這個東西
然後現在有展出來
但是Kyber它一個比較大的問題
我們在過去的技術有跟大家聊到
其實最主要就是
因為它的工藝是真的是比較複雜一點
所以甚至還會再有進一步的一些遞延
都是有機會發生的
在過程之中可能就會去折衷
就是我們不要一次跳這麼高的一個技術門檻
我們可能就是慢慢的推過去
所以導致像Kyber大家比較去關注的是
像什麼正交的結構
後面的背板
Midplan
然後或者說裡面的Cube
當然Cube有用在LPU裡面
這些東西算是在市場裡面蠻熱門
過去會大家很關注的題材
隨著地言
可能有些人就會不去注意它
但是我覺得有招一拳
他們都是還是會再回來的
因為看到這些產品
還是覺得非常的感動
他們真的是帶領這些科技業的從業人員
一起去做一些
為了AI非常大的技術突破
當然就要靠大家的腦力跟幹
一定是要幹到爆炸
才可以持續的去做這樣子的推進
所以Enterprise整體來看
我覺得跟過去是差不多的
並沒有太多的新鮮的東西
後來我們就是到了南港區域
有看NVIDIA消費端相關的一些內容
這次的消費端的展示
我是非常喜歡的
就是跟過去比起來
但過去相當初跟大家分享說
你可以跟遊戲裡面的NPC互動
或什麼
那個就是比較平常是科幻的情節
還記得在一兩年前不是很多人都講嗎
以後都是用AI做遊戲什麼的
那時候我們就是有比較大膽的逆風去提出一個說法
就是其實你去玩一個遊戲
你是要玩一個設計好的體驗
你懂我意思嗎
你不是要玩一個隨機gen出來的東西
你就是因為知道這款遊戲好玩
或者說你知道這個就是小島秀夫做的
你才要去玩嘛
你為什麼要玩一個隨機gen的
所以你真的要對我的遊戲
去產生一些隨機性的話
那可能是產生在可能某部分的對話
你可以tele made
因為今天是我的生日
或者說因為我的名字叫什麼
你會跟我去做對話這邊可以去做一些調整我覺得是OK的可是你說整個劇情整個場景要為了我去做一個客製化的設定也是之前很多那種屌萃AI的人在講我覺得那個是很不實際的
所以我們在今年就比較沒有看到
他們去強調說在電玩裡面
去做一些那種可能DIY
或是Custom Made的東西
反而是在工作旅遊上面
去做了許多的加強
我就看到像市場中
現在大家都非常不喜歡的Adobe
因為大家認為說AI可以深圖
AI可以改圖
所以Adobe就是要BBQ
但這次很好玩的一點是
甚至會感覺說NVIDIA跟Adobe是不是有什麼
當然他們已經有公佈一些合作
只有我相信檯面下應該有更多深度的合作
跟開發案在進行中
為什麼
因為它會去展示說
不只是他們的硬體去Custom
然後For Adobe的應用
然後在Adobe這邊的軟體
也會去做可以去符合RTX Spark的一種設計
讓它可以跑得更加的順暢
他們展出的內容像
有些是沒有使用RTX Spark的筆電去跑的話
他去跑Premiere或是跑Photoshop
他就要花很長的一段時間
如果今天是RTX Spark的話
他可以只花1 3或1 5的時間就跑完
他還幫你把每個鏡頭切換的時間點都抓出來
所以剪片就變得非常快
那這邊你會注意到兩個極端嗎?
現在有一派的人就說以後都是AI剪片或什麼的
這樣說這個就像是很多人會講說以後就是AI發文就好
現在很多人會用Claw去
在他的粉專或是可能他的Act上面去做發文
我都會跟大家講說
這個對我來講
他其實有點像是一個自殺的行徑
為什麼
因為我絕對不會想要把我的
在網路上的各種形象或什麼的
去完全的做自動化
因為你今天不是什麼愛買
什麼全聯加熱服
你再推一個折扣訊息
如果你推的信息都是那種千篇一律
大家最後一看都知道是AI的
你的互動跟觸及一定會掉的超級快
所以這個時代當然有很多自動化的東西
有很多AI的東西看起來是很酷
Fascinating 大家很喜歡
但換個角度
其實我相信越來越多人會對於這種東西
很憎恨 討厭 AI Slop 超級不喜歡
然後外加真的想去找一些有人味的東西
所以像這樣子的自動化我是不喜歡的
我覺得像我AI全自動剪片
如果強調如果你今天是一個
就是你每天要重複好幾次的
全聯的某一個東西特價
你讓AI去剪我覺得沒有問題
可是如果是你身為一個創作者
你是導演
你是編劇
或是說你是一個老師
你用AI去做這個
我覺得你是加速你的滅亡所以這個其實跟世間的蠻多東西或是我自己的價值觀一直都是契合的就是世界上是有光譜的你說有沒有東西是要用AI的全自動化去有 就像我剛剛前面講的折扣訊息
每日的折扣訊息 每日的消息推播
你用自動化去做 太適合了
但是如果你今天是有一些人格特質的東西在裡面
大家喜歡你是你的人格特質的
你用AI去自動化這件事情
你是把自己推到棺材裡面
所以買多東西我覺得還是要那個味道在
就是你不能跟我講說
下有一個什麼很強的AI導演
然後以後大家就會看這個AI導演
沒有 老子要看諾蘭
我就是想看諾蘭
我就是想看塔倫提諾蘭
我覺得他的味道
就算他的味道可能比較鈍一點
so I just like
所以要去記得這樣的一個差距
可能像過去的AI的展會都比較強調
就像我們剛剛講
那種全自動AI可以做所有東西
人類拜拜
sayonara
這樣的一個嘗試
那現在我覺得今年
甚至是不只是NVIDIA
在很多的談位都有感覺到
越來越少人去強調
我們要走向一個沒有人的世界
反而現在是
我覺得把人重新的放到舞台的正中間
這也是我喜歡的
這也是我覺得是對的
這也是為什麼我會再過去多次的表達
我對anthropic老闆
雖然我知道anthropic產品真的很好用
我有在用
可是他的發文實在是令人不敢苟同
怎麼講整天都是在講說
我們東西多可怕
會有多少人死也有什麼的
像最近David Sachs的一個PO文
就是以前川普的AI撒謊
我覺得他講的這段超噓的
最好也是給這些人一些當頭棒喝
你整天在講說
你的產品會讓一堆white collar jobs不見
你會讓一堆人
可能失去活著的目的或什麼的
你甚至會導致global crisis
可能會有一些核武的危機
或是互相害
害對方的飛彈
然後把人家炸飛
AI可以做什麼什麼
你這個意思代表說
你要被我們收歸國有
如果說你這個企業在推的這件事情
是會造成這樣的一個結果
會造成人道危機
會造成經濟的困難的話
那怎麼可能讓你繼續發展嗎
把你收回國有
或是說給你超大的一個監管
給你放一個很大的一個拘束器
這不是超級合理的事情嗎
每一任總統都會想做這件事情
每一個百姓
像前面聽到一些演講超級不爽的
那些Ivy League名校的一些學生
大家一定都支持這件事情
你要毀滅我們
我怎麼可能讓你繼續做下去
所以我覺得越來越多人
有發現這件事情
那抑或是不一定是有發現
這麼人文的一個思考
而是他單純的去從他們可能過往推的那些像過去一兩年媽 到處都機械狗是怎樣我不是說機械狗不好我又不是說什麼Humanoid不好可是你們每個人都在出機械狗就很明顯就是在跟風
你這機械狗要用在哪裡
甚至有些是那種超廢的功能
然後他們還是要講的煞有其事
因為AI因為怎麼樣
所以全部都是機械狗
再來就是一些那種AI的小Gadget
其實當下看會覺得很酷
可是真的看久之後
我覺得會審美麻木
就是你真的會覺得非常非常的煩躁
那今年真的都是少掉很多這樣子的東西
更加的去強調說
人跟機器的一個結合
所以像是可能大家在市場中
人人喊打的Adobe
就是說你死定了啦
AI取代的第一棒
結果竟然在NVIDIA的消費展會裡面
當然這個是沒有對外站的
所以可能你要從一些報導裡面
才會看到一些相關的圖片跟訊息
竟然有大量的曝光
他們其實是跟他在做一個
很深度的合作之類的
當然這邊不知道要cue大家說
所以Adobe的第一點到了
畢竟這個對我來講
是一個比較相對不熟悉的領域
只是他很有趣的是
就是一個大家在市場上說
要被淘汰的某個東西
竟然看得出來是他們深度合作的夥伴
甚至為了軟體
他們可能在硬體上面有去做一些調整
為什麼RTX Spark可以去做到這些這麼厲害的東西
最主要就是它Unified Memory
就是說它把整個記憶體的Pool都可以拿來用
所以我可以放進去更大的模型
我可以一次處理更多的參數
所以它有去展示
像它可以去把New York City
可能30到50block之間的一個地貌
直接在一瞬間就Render出來
而且它的速度超級快
它不會因為說什麼你轉頭
然後它就需要去載路
或者說會卡頓之類的
非常的順
我就想說
因為以前我們都知道說
每次的GTA出來
它就是一個硬體大屠殺
甚至是可能連
當下台面上最強大的硬體
都沒有辦法去跑它的最高效能
你要等到可能一兩年之後才有辦法
那今年我覺得會有一些變化
就是可能在AI的輔助之下
不管是NVDLSS什麼的
或者說去幫你補針之類的
就是它的這個針呢
並不是每一針都是直接去把它 render 出來
尤其是用AI去算的
所以它會讓硬體的負載可以再更加的大一點
然後外加 unified memory 的一個處理
在這樣的一個展示之下
其實我已經可以去想像到說一些3A大作
那它可能可以去把更好的畫面呈現給玩家
而不用讓玩家一定要去追求
可能最貴的硬體設備
也可以達到就是說在硬體跟軟體的協作之下
軟體讓硬體裝上了一雙翅膀
差不多這樣的一個感受
所以其實整個展規看下來的東西都是在聚焦
如何讓一些軟體執行得更快
剪片修圖
或者說去做設計跟打遊戲
怎麼樣跑得超級順
我認為這個是
我自己會很意外
我會講這樣的話
如果我是兩三年前
一開始去看AI展看到這個
我一定會覺得不太對
你應該要跟我去demo一些未來的可能性
可是在經過兩年的瘋狂的審美疲勞之後
現在就會覺得這些東西是實際上
我一看就知道會影響到我的工作
我的生活或者說我的娛樂
它會直接去做很大幅度的耀神
所以看到這樣的東西是覺得超級的開心
在聯發課這邊
我有去跟他們聊了一下
因為其實RTX Spark它會分兩個規格
反正就N1X跟N1
比較高規格的話
它的ASP應該就是會弱
我們不是在講晶片
我們在講說筆電出去
應該大家要買到的話
要9萬到10萬台幣左右
如果是N1比較低規格的話
應該是會在5-6萬左右
當然其實我也覺得要去買這個東西
應該要直上
雖然大家都知道我是直上宅
所以你什麼都會推直上
可是這個是真的要直上
為什麼因為重點就是
你要有這麼大的Unified Memory
你就知道有這麼大的記憶體Pro
所以你買比較低規一點的
其實我會覺得你應該會蠻失望的
因為有很多很酷的嘗試
或者是說可能過去一兩年
還不敢拿出來
已經有這樣子的東西
但是知道拿出來
因為它會卡頓
你Demo一定會給大家笑死
就是因為它有很大的Unified Memory Pro
所以我會覺得說
那個記憶體的容量是很大的關鍵
你就是必須要買到那個頂規
你才可以去跑一些
Local端的Agentic AI
或者說去跑前面所講到的
超快的剪片修圖跟圖像rendering什麼的
或者說遊戲裡面的補真什麼的
那應該都是需要大量的memory
才可以去支撐這樣的事情
所以我自己目前的猜想
就是等到RTX上了之後
應該會是高階的銷量要好一點
當然這是在理性的結果之下
說不定很多人是長先黨
然後他也沒有認真去研究
他想說先買一個入門款
然後結果入門款賣得更好
但我會覺得說
買入門款的人應該會幹掉
我會覺得說他們應該會幹掉
因為你要去塞很大的模型
或是要做上述的東西
你都需要大量的記憶體跟大量的算力
所以應該是要一次買到位才會有機會
這個產品會不會跟過去的
像高通或我們知道MacBook
大家都有在推Local AI
高通的那一次
嚴格上來說是有一點失敗
不能夠怪它
而是說時間還沒有到
類似AI PIN那時候出來
我們也講說它在幾年之後說不定有機會
可是在這個時間點出來就一定是沒有辦法
因為時間是還沒有到的
我覺得這是RTX Spark
目前存用Demo的內容來看我覺得它成功的機率會是高的但它還缺臨門一角臨門一角是什麼因為我說的成功機率高是based on我現在的一個生活的做法
是怎麼樣
我用了很多的Properacity Computer
我已經開始有用很多的AI的內容
所以這些AI的內容對我來講
因為我現在用的AI
並不是可能一般消費者
會去接觸到的我一個月幾百塊之中
我是一個月是付6000固定的月費
然後外加我還會再去額外的買Token
因為這東西太好用了
它已經是在我的實務層面
就要說我現在要去
買一些紅酒
我要知道說他在拍賣的價格
或說他在各個網站上的評價是怎麼樣
其實我透過Agenti AI去爬超級快
而且很準確
就是他會去檢查資料
當然他準確跟超級快的一個代價是什麼
就是說要花蠻多的錢
所以其實每個月可能都花了幾萬塊在AI上面
而且他是很被動的一直出資進去
因為就好用嘛
你一直用嘛他就一直上去
所以不是說什麼
我去買一個東西那我都沒有在用
而是因為你就是真的把用量都用完了
所以在我的角度會去考量的是
如果說有些東西可以把它
結合到地端的模型的話
就類似我們前面在聊Snowflake
可能有些東西下次要外包到LA
沒有辦法
等到你開始有些data
把它建立進來的時候
有些東西可以在地端直接去跑的話
說不定每個月你就可以省下
我們隨便舉例1萬塊好了
你省10個月你的筆電就回來了
那是不是就很合理
就類似說像XAI
現在把它的Colossus
租給Anthropic
那個其實算下來就是說
一年內就回本了
對你來說
你是不是就很有動機去買這個硬體
所以我目前看下來會認為
以我的實用情境來說
我非常有動機去買它
可是不是每個人會這樣子做
所以那時候就問了
聯發哥幫我展示的這位大哥
我就說這個可不可以打遊戲
他就說NVIDIA的東西一定都是可以打遊戲
因為他們就是從遊戲起家的
這個RTX PARK
它雖然是很小的一部晶片
可是它大概是等效5070的東西
我就覺得這是有搞頭的
如果說它是可以做到5070
並且因為在大量的記憶體之下
可以有很多AI的功能導入
甚至去優化一些遊戲
或者說一些軟體的表現的話
搞不好可以把5070等效的表現
又推到一個更新的高度
在後面的一些軟體更新跟優化上
它拿來打遊戲就會很讚
就是說你花10萬塊去買一個
你不要想要的是AI筆電
因為AI不一定是很多人會用的東西
但是它現在是AI筆電
slash電競筆電
那這樣就不一樣
因為電競筆電本來就蠻貴的
可是這一台電競筆電
雖然他們現在不會這樣去行銷它
但是我會用這樣去看它
這台電競筆電
可能比一般電競筆電要再貴一點可是它是輕薄的因為很多電競筆電是超級厚的然後它可能放很多的風扇或什麼的當然其實我們家講可能都太快了因為你不知道它會不會後來跑電腦
一些什麼軟體
或是說可能像是遊戲
然後會有熱當的狀況產生
這個不太確定
你怎麼可以做這麼輕薄
所以這個還要再觀察
但如果說它在遊戲的部分表現很好的話
你買這台筆電
你就試想吧
GTA6是不是要出了
你買這台筆電可以直接無痛打GTA6
買不買還可以順便搞AI
買不買買
很多人就會覺得說賣
媽的 shut up take my money
所以我會認為說
如果可以把遊戲的東西
稍微的加強去講的話
搭配前面的工作性的軟體
生產力軟體
不管是剪片修圖什麼的
然後搭配Augentic的Local AI
大量的參數可以直接掛進去
我覺得這台筆電
至少我會買的很高興
而且我覺得它比前面的幾款AI筆電
會有更高的一個成功機率
大概這樣子
最後我們去看ASUS ROG
我覺得這次ROG也是精銳進出
他們已經是洪洪之力了 很明顯
簡單講他們跟市面上的太太們宣戰
真的是直接宣戰
他們做出很多的酷東西
我稍微的側面了解一下
其實好像今年的消費性廠家
蠻多都做了很多的酷東西
不管是在鍵盤上面很誇張
現在開始會做一些什麼客製化
或者說很酷的內容
一些什麼鍵帽
它已經是像盲盒一樣可以用抽的
後面還有一個什麼24K鍍金的小背板
但是坐在那個根本就不會有人看到的地方
但是說你要低調奢華要炫一下的話
找那個女生來家裡看貓咪的時候
那個鍵盤可以不小心
鍵盤翻過來了
怎麼會有一個24K金的金卡在這呢
送你然後可能就直接就結婚了
所以他們有很多這種看起來超級中二的東西
就是花一堆心力去強調產品的外觀
連實用性的部分也都做得很好
為什麼?因為消費級的表現不好
所以大家都必須要使出權力
然後看怎麼樣去吸引到更多的消費者
所以看到了不管是他們跟T1聯名的顯示卡
然後再來就是像那些鍵盤滑鼠
或是說硬體電腦
你知道現在很誇張
而且它的主機以前我們的主機是怎樣
就是說RGB三原色
我講說那個是宅男的卜文燈
只是沒有想到卜文燈已經進階到
我就直接放一個面板在那邊
然後上面可以去放自己客製化
自己去選的影片
那一開始我看到想說
誰會買這個東西然後我隔壁那個天傳法師又跟我去看站他直接想說我會買他直接說他會買所以立刻就談成了一個生意然後看完之後就立刻被說服了所以你說電玩展是不是有很多
像剛剛前面講
無關緊要的人的時候跑進來
像那個法師他其實根本就不需要看展
他看線型的
他那屌你基本面傻小
他根本不管
他進來隨便看一下
你看他就直接就買一台電腦了
然後前面一堆那種哈拉一大堆講說
什麼那個誰進來
你們到底會花多少錢
你們有花多少錢
隨便找一個像我講的這種路人進去
20萬的電腦直接就要給他刷下去
他就直接就要買了
但現場沒有賣
他後面就是要直接去買
然後看著周邊
他看了之後他就是要直接包鬼要全包
所以你看大家還是要去敞開心胸
就是一些那種感覺是
他平常根本不會來看展的
他被我帶來看
然後他就
就是要買下去
這個是一些意外的發展
反正總之就是ROG的各種產品
現在開始是往那種精緻化的方向去走
然後外甲他們有給我展了一個眼鏡
這個眼鏡也非常厲害
我看下來我感覺它有點像是
輕量化的Apple Vision Pro
我畢竟說當那時候Vision Pro出來
我去買的時候
我已經知道我自己會是一個盤子
但我其實還是蠻喜歡這個產品的
我對它詬病的點就是說它真的太重
所以我不會想要整天把它拿出來
到現在老實跟大家說
它就是放著在那邊養灰塵
雖然在過去有一個感動時刻
就是我曾經用它來錄兒子
後來去回放這些影片的時候很感動
那會有換肢的效應
好像說你真的抱到這個孩子
那還是非常感動
可是真的太重了
它在生活中是難以去做應用的
所以這個就是回到
我們剛剛前面所聊到的一個概念
就是什麼東西是讓你在daily basis
你也可以去使用的東西
這非常重要的
你不可以跟我講太多太科幻的東西
可是它要付出巨大的代價
對人家來講就是很難去做到每天的嘗試
可是ROG的這款眼鏡戴上去之後
它給我的第一個感受是
它的畫面是非常好的
然後跟流暢度或什麼的
那就像是我那時候在看Vision Pro
甚至是超越人
然後它只是一個眼鏡的重量
所以我很難去想像說
你在給他們一兩年的時間
他們會把這個東西玩成什麼樣子
所以其實我當下的想法就是說
眼鏡可能真的是非常有搞頭的東西
可能我們過去看了很多的VRGoggles
然後跟AR的一些demo
我們覺得說這東西可能還太遠
可是這次的電腦展
綜合大家前面所講的東西
他給我的感受就是說
Future is now
就是所有東西之下都可以立刻實現的
而不是說停留在紙上尬吹的環節
總之就是收穫非常多
最後Micky帶我們去看了ASUS的施展
他們一樣在南港展覽館裡面
有包一個小空間
以前上上去的時候
其實裡面有什麼機械狗
這次一樣沒有看到機械狗
但是他們多了蠻多
除了去展示
伺服器之外
伺服器一樣
我覺得反正現在大家都差不多
但是他有去秀了一些軟體的應用
然後這些軟體的應用
可以快速的去識別說
哪個地方
哪一排的伺服器的哪一個環節
可能目前是有問題的
可以立刻去做一些狀況的排除
他是跟我講說
這些軟體的應用
其實稱為我節目所講的
你沒有辦法很輕鬆的說
有AI agent
所以就不需要所有的軟體
因為真的不是這樣子
有些東西會下去
有些東西會上來
在這些AI的coding協助之下
他們更是做出了很多很實用的軟體
如果客戶要跟他們買這些東西的話
都可以幫斗一起出去給他
所以看起來是印象深刻
所以總之就是以上我電腦展的感受
這次覺得是把很多
可能在過去是像紙上彈屏的東西
直接把它非常紮實的展現出來
然後去加速大家的工作
他要做的訴求並不是在告訴你說
這是一個無人的世界
所有東西都自動化去跑
它告訴你說
這是一個讓你變得非常輕鬆的世界
你只要去下個指令
你只要稍微看一下
拿著咖啡讓你的電腦去跑
它就可以完成你的很多任務
同時你還是會維持很多的個人化色彩在裡面
你不會因為說讓AI去做
然後產出一個Random的結果
它是把各種產出跟執行
變得更加的可視化
跟可以直接很無腦的
類似像是No Code的一個形式
你可以用Drag and Place的方式
就可以完成超多事情
我覺得這個是我們期待的一個未來
我覺得這也是會讓產業加速的一個
很有機會的一個未來
所以目前是覺得非常喜歡這一次的電腦展
大概這樣簡單跟大家分享一下
因為聊一聊就已經沒有時間了
沒有時間跟大家聊說
因為大家都知道說像昨天夜盤
已經出現了大場面
最深的時候
我看台子有摸到-10%
後來拉到-6-7%
所以下禮拜大家就是brace for impact
也沒有什麼好講的
因為我們本來就知道說
你舒服久了
你就是會要還
一定會有天閥
一定會有天錢
然後你在舒服的當下
你跟大家講
當然老聽眾一定都知道
大家都一定隨時做好心理準備
可是新的人一定不相信
股票只會漲
你看每天跌個一趴在那邊幹幹叫
禮拜一就有大場面了
可是以我自己的角度來講
我覺得這樣子去洗一下蟲
覺得是好事
禮拜一這樣殺一殺
如果有些是鎖死的話
可能就需要在兩三天的時間
去把裡面的這些槓桿仔給清掉
融資是融最大的
股息槓最大
其實過去的幾天已經有在殺股息了那種股息槓最大你看到一大堆股息8.45分開盤直接開超低然後接著馬上拉上來的你知道怎麼會開一個超低嗎那就是那些人自殺了因為沒有辦法誰叫你要槓這麼大
然後就被洗掉了
所以在後面可能還會有一陣子的
心風邪雨
但其實整體看下來我覺得
我們在產業端這邊
是沒有看到什麼太多的問題
特別是這次去電腦展
更是充滿了很多的信心
所以我覺得過程中
漲多也會可能
跌的時候也會多一點
後面整理之後
我們再看新的方向在哪裡
再持續的跟大家分享
希望大家在下禮拜一
當然我們美股的朋友們
包含像我自己
禮拜五已經去承受了
禮拜一換台股要承受一下
大家要做好自己的心理準備
接下來我們進去的部分
第一位 林口區京城武
都在同間健身房
怎麼完全沒有遇到過
夢宮您好 有兩點要請教
一 要怎麼學川普語音包
嘗試好幾次都不像
二 目前25歲
美股績效YTD
目前是25%
括號自知偏爛
主要操作大全值股
但不太會有大漲大跌
採取短期持有獲利
那雖然資金輪動較快
但常有賣飛的情況
有什麼操作建議
能夠開進口唱七里香嗎
祝您全家健康幸福愛您
從上集就講
就像已經開始有那個吃土的味道
只唱得出救命
現在沒有辦法唱七里香
那再來川普的語音包
我覺得你可以加上手勢
你是看加上手勢
然後跟稍微往前傾
頭要這樣歪一點點
應該就會更有辦法
那再來說
你自己都知道說
計較沒有到很好
那你再去溫西部的操作
我覺得也是沒有什麼用
就是有时候还是要从大方向去改变
选择比较重要
那再来才能努力
下面一位
对股市猛猛咚咚的小蜥蜴
向帅气幸福勇猛的
梦恭大大许愿
您好
最近因为男友的关系接触骨癌
男友是您的忠实粉丝
常常听他梦恭长梦恭短
也跟我分享一些贵节目的乐趣
还有梦恭大大的幸福家庭
那在此想
请梦恭大大用最幸福缅满的声音
祝6月3号生日的
熏熏生日快乐
谢谢帅气幸福勇猛的梦恭大大
夢宮請你跟自己說
那四個字
你娘卡好
或是用跟秋口聲音祝自己生日快樂
生日快樂愛您
另外也在想夢宮484最近被太多人說生日快樂才突然狂暴發言
因為這兩個留言都跟生日有關
其實上次那個根本就沒有狂暴發言
我自己是覺得還蠻好笑的
只是因為那個媽媽她說她要胎叫
所以就我怎麼可以後面亂接話
但我其實還蠻喜歡亂接話
因為上次亂接的話嚴格上來講叫普遍級的
我不知道大家是活在什麼粉紅泡泡的世界
因為發現
絕大多數的聽眾都說很好笑很好玩還是有少部分就是說好像我講了什麼很嚴重的話趕快滾回去看巧虎還是有很多這種怪小還是覺得這個節目大了有時候會撈到一些我真的很不喜歡的人你覺得這個很嚴重
你趕快回去聽巧虎啦
下面一位
我白頭紅輕心啦
6月6號是什麼好日子
變電到可以吹一輩子
夢公你聽過第二根腳趾頭比大拇指長的玄學嗎
據說第二根腳趾較長的俗稱吸臘腳
人生通常順遂
不需要去走太多的彎路
不知道夢公奇卡的腳趾頭是什麼腳
我有試著找你穿拖鞋的照片放大來看
但還是看不太清楚
如果有心被您唸到留言
可以PO在線洞
你腳趾頭給我看嗎
拜託了 真是快樂 愛您
那對了 我也會拍我的腳趾頭給你看
我一點都不想看
拜託不要突然間什麼拍腳趾頭
還什麼奇怪的照片
有些奇怪照片不要講
講的怕給人家一些靈感
但我有一個朋友他開那個按摩店
然後就會有人傳那個屌照給他
那有想法 整組直接傳給他
然後他就要去報警才麻煩
那腳的話
我剛剛叫做什麼羅馬腳
就是一二三四
那是比較這個序列排列的
那如果是希臘腳的話
就是第二根比較長
我知道很多人都是這樣子
我們家裡也有人是那樣子
我不是我是
第二根是拍在第一根後面
這種大概是這樣
那你說
第二根比較長的比較順遂
好像還好
下面一位
2026績效大報社
三個問題想問
16小孩的時候會放著6還是一直盯著
孩子阿公都說放給他自己玩就好
每天都愛戴他
但我戴的時候就是沒有辦法
哪不全程盯著
括號非生父
二 公口問題
你是屬於無毛派還是有毛派
因為你們是東西方合併家庭會請向哪一邊
如果是無毛派會請人處理嗎
三 一直看到Flex有人在謝琴講
Mareo跟被動電鍵什麼的
總覺得這些人很快樂寶貝
還是我才是
就是覺得看得很白痴
第一個 我是屬於會盯著看的
如果說你們家是長輩去放小孩的話
我更覺得要盯著看
因為長輩的速度會比較慢一點
所以建議都還是要看著
第二格是無毛派有毛派
我覺得有比較好一點
第三個我也是蠻不喜歡這樣子的東西
因為像之前大概半年還一年前
我就印象深刻
那時候也是反正我在美國
也是突然間Killing Spree
表現的再來蠻好的
然後後來因為我在看好SDR Labs
SDR Labs大家都知道說
它從200多就直接摔到100
反正就直接摔成狗就對了
我是沒有後來去看怎麼樣
可是那時候我就記得說
有蠻多人就說你看它過去表現超強
就是無腦跟就對了
就是支持他
其實我不喜歡看到這種因為什麼叫做支持我什麼叫無腦跟我因為老實講你賺錢與否跟我一點關係都沒有我們這邊也沒有說什麼收費所以如果你在外面催我很好的話
我會賺比較多錢
沒有就是蠻多人會把他自己的選擇外包給我
就是說因為我是相信夢工
所以我幹嘛
所以我看到這種
我想法跟你一樣
但我很意外有人的想法跟我一樣
因為我有一般聽眾只會覺得
就蠻中性的看這件事情
但我自己會覺得
媽的那你自己的事情
就像現在有些人開始會說什麼
聽我講完
他就決定要去做什麼事
沒有你幹你不要說那是我
那是你自己的事情
你不要把選擇好像說放在別人身上
我也不是說什麼我要去逃避者什麼
如果今天是覺得說我是你的financial advisor
我收你的錢
我是你的理專
你當然是要找我負責
這是沒有問題
可是我也沒有收你錢
我在節目分享東西
老實講我也覺得這個節目的走勢
實際上還蠻特別的
最早其實真的是我
為了要去交一些股票圈的朋友
有這個東西
然後後來就出圈了
所以出圈之後
你發現我有些東西會講的比較瘦一點
因為有些聽眾是不特定多數人
他不一定懂股票
你講的這個東西
嚴格來說你有機會會害到他
如果大家看久會知道說一些標的
我們不用講西部每個標的
我們講台股好了
台股這種
現在4萬多點的一個股票
然後竟然在過程中這麼多人會賠錢
所以一個同樣的東西
還是會有很多人賠錢
那個除了說一些技術實力
認知能力之外
腦力抗壓性或什麼
全部都要去放行考驗
所以就是不要去講說
我都是聽誰講的然後我就去買
我覺得這種人就是拿槍跟敗的
拿槍跟敗的
你有看過哪一個拿槍跟敗的
最後面走的很好的
大家自己他媽的動動腦
所以我也是覺得看這種人
會比較浮躁一點
下面一位
宜蘭小農挺為腰酸被痛的小農
害夢宮小弟身受腰酸被痛
困擾好一陣子了
本來想說應該是長期務農
加上年紀增長的關係
就沒有太在意
聽到夢宮分享之後才開始在想
也許我不必如此
對那時候就是
我的想法真的這樣
也許我不用這樣子
不知道要怎麼像孟公這樣的健身教練
有什麼關鍵字
能不能請Ran哥分享一下
另外孟公如果有空來宜蘭
歡迎來樹仔像農場走走
我很樂意帶你們全家夏田體驗種到
非常感謝
可能不是體驗
可能如果說這樣的盤維持一段時間的話
就請兄弟可以給我一個工作
我們以前也是苗栗會種牛
我們會桿牛
以前家族也有種田的基因
所以我相信這個工作我可以勝任
請老闆到時候考慮我
再來講說要找什麼樣的關鍵字
那個叫做功能性訓練
你去找一下功能性訓練
然後搭配物理治療師
因為我的想法就是
跟你一開始一樣
反正我就是年紀大了
我就是久坐一定會這樣子或什麼的
然後後來就是開始去做一些訓練之後
發現說身體有逐漸在改善
所以當你的問題從10個
你就是放腿的
幹我不管了 死了算了
到你剩下兩個
剩下兩個你就會去認真想說
那我是不是要認真去解決這兩個問題
那我覺得找物理治療師的幫助也很大
所以有點像說
你終於把注意力放到這個東西上面
你除了有功能性訓練
或者是物理治療師
然後再來我自己平常也會去找伸展師
就直接把所有的東西都中了起來
那就是講說你不要只是讓我好像暫時不痛
我現在就是要解決這個問題
然後請大家幫忙集思廣義之後
就慢慢的有去識別出問題
就真的把它解決掉
那我甚至覺得最誇張的是
原來跟呼吸這麼有關係
當我開始學會去做複式呼吸
而且不只是到腹
你還要去Cue到你的背
我幫我們在節目講過
應該是有講過
反正就是你的
要怎麼樣讓你的呼吸感覺會到你的背
特別是久做足
你在呼吸的時候
你適合把一個拳頭放在你的
就是你平常會痛到下背那邊
然後在吸氣的時候要讓你的氣去鼓那個地方
然後你就用這個方式去做
去頂著你可能靠背的東西
你會一瞬間就發現說你的背變得比較舒服
你氣有吸下去就舒服很多
所以這只是其中一環
那當然還有像什麼弓箭步
那不是一般的弓箭步
是有主力訓練的
因為他已經知道說我的左下背是比較弱一點的
那左下背可能是跟打網球
用右手去揮去誘發他
本來沒有那麼痛
後來變更痛是因為這樣
那要怎麼樣去解決左下背呢
那可能就是弓箭步的時候
你的右手膝蓋要頂著東西
那去往右邊去扭它
等於說把你的左邊的寬給炫回來
反正有很多這種細項的東西
可是你沒有去找專業人士
一一的幫你檢查
你抓不出這種問題
所以我建議大家可以去試看看
去把這個問題一一解決掉
因為是可以被解決的
像我的問題就已經解決超過一半了
那下面一位
JHH底線73希望被念到part7
莫公好去年年底跟老公登記結婚
有幸上次被你念到真開心
今年出國回來之後
發現放鬆的感覺真的很棒
之前一直有金錢焦慮
不敢花錢
都要感謝老公推我一把
期待去福岡能夠看到若曦
5月18號是邱先生的生日
上次劉恩沒有念到
雖然他生日過了
還會吃醋我整天說
夢公說
但我最愛的還是老公
請夢公用肌肉猛男的聲音
祝我老公生日快樂
下次再來試試我生日的劉恩密碼
祝福夢公一家
身體健康平安快樂
愛你我愛你
希望你們兩個可以快樂健康
確實把金錢焦慮給放下
金錢焦慮其實它不只是金錢的焦慮
它還包含著
因為你要去獲得更多的金錢
你要投出很多的勞務或者說去動腦所以它整體來說是一個非常累人的事情稍微的把這種東西給放掉稍微讓自己腦筋空下來那確實是一個很好的體驗希望你可以持續維持這樣子的體驗
下面一位
Samo Chin
你混蛋但我喜歡
聽完上集脫序的胎叫跟祝福
我真的覺得夢宮太糟糕
但這就是你不用覺得這樣不好
還記得你上台通的時候有分享
第一次Lisa過來就帶去給你朋友認識
當下你朋友就幹幹叫
我覺得就是因為你這麼糟糕
還能夠擁有Lisa
是我的話當下一定也是幹幹叫
by the way
去年底开始资产不容易开始加速向前
但因为家中太多贪小便宜去接触大陆币圈的传直销
因此还贷款了一笔钱
最近为了让老婆安心
就把每日股都清完帮助她还贷款
让我觉得人生好难
不知道
当然家里遇到这种事情
我老实说
如果是我的话
我会蛮生气的
但发生了就要去处理
因为毕竟两夫妻在一起
这样讲的
老婆或是說老公是你各位跟我自己
我們這一輩子唯一可以選擇的家人
對吧 你爸媽你不能選嘛
你生下來就是配這兩個
或甚至是一個
或甚至是不知道你爸媽是誰你也不知道
但那是天注定的
你的小孩嚴格上來說
你能夠決定要不要讓他出來
可是出來之後你也是沒得選
那就是跟你了
他個性是怎麼樣你沒得選
可是老公跟老婆是可以選的
所以當一個東西是你可以選擇的
然後結果他可能稍微的雷了一下
有時候會生氣吧
會怎麼樣吧
會覺得說我怎麼會做出這樣判斷
是不是要換人或什麼的
所以會比較容易有那種挫折感
可是你要換個角度說
就是每個人都會犯錯
那今天可能他犯的錯是這種
老實講你說拿錢還一還就解決了
搞不好之後你犯的錯是什麼
你犯的錯是你的身體不好
然後你臥病在床
結果是你老婆來照顧你之類的
所以我覺得夫妻就是要互相的扶持
當下有脾氣已經正常的
就是對方犯了什麼錯或怎麼樣的
可能是講了很多次
你怎麼還是一樣會被雷
怎麼還是會貪心
可是你要知道
有一天你也可能會犯錯
老婆跟老公是唯一一個
就是我們這輩子
可以自己選的家人
所以還是要好好地照顧一下
如果對方是有悔悟
是有去修正的
那我們就是把它散口
這個是沒有問題的
當然沒有悔悟沒有修正
還一直要往死裡去的
另當別論
大概這樣
下面一位
女人就是見
他講的不錯講
靴子裡有蛇
鋼門裡也有
開始有怪咖出來
老闆很久沒有鬼叫
可以請大交醫生給我聽嗎
我現在已經
我已經交不出來了
我已經沒有力氣了我看到昨天那個盤我沒有力氣了想問來老闆會買不知道為什麼在漲的股票嗎這到底問是什麼問題啊這不是都講到爛掉的為什麼要去買一個我不知道什麼在漲的我知道為什麼在漲了這麼多
為什麼我要去買一個
我不知道為什麼在漲的
你去買這種就很容易受傷了
就想記住面有記住好
尤其還要衝進去
這個死掉的機率都偏高了我覺得
那有發現龍岩幾乎每年都會來一波很凶狠的漲勢
只是完全不懂為什麼會漲
1月14號發現漲停後隔天果斷試駕單上車
一週後一根綠K就出場了
面對不知道上漲理由的股票
阿老闆會怎麼抓停損停利
這個就是有點像說去玩樂透的感覺
我感覺有點像
只是勝率比樂透高蠻多的東西
我是不會去做這樣子的事情
我也不鼓勵去做這樣子的事情
你說一根綠K就出場
我覺得還OK
簡單講就是說
你是技術面進來技術面出去
前後邏輯一樣是OK的
只是我不會去做這種事情
就像我不會去做什麼
無本當衝
什麼每日當衝
我不做這種事
很多人會跟你鼓吹
有些事情就是你做的期望就不高
所以就不要浪费生命去做那样的事情
如果你还是做得很开心的话
那就加油
下面一位
老黄懂吃懂太常跳过
我要当个好爸爸
宝宝一定是忘了待
梦说大
我老婆因为身体有些状况
难以自然受孕
今天我们做了两次试管
第一次失败十分沮丧
终于在第二次成功
当下听到消息激动了落泪
非常心疼老婆哀真的辛苦
到了第六周回诊的时候
医生帮我测了心跳
至今忘不了宝宝有力的心跳声
但非常遗憾
在第八周准备领妈妈手册的时候
检查出宝宝胎庭
真的很难过也难以接受这个事实
但我们都告诉彼此宝宝一定是东西忘了带
我们会打起精神准备好迎接他再次到来
我觉得这种事情用这样的心态处理是对的
希望你们可以持续的维持正向
就像刚才前面提到的一小段
因为我们在人生之中
我们不知道会遇到什么事情
其实很多我们的苦难
不然说像之前有一个工作到
让他可能压力很大很忧郁的
我那時候也是有點
就是可能不勝發言
在一些人的眼中
我就跟他講說
你這根本沒什麼
因為那真的沒什麼
因為只要你可以轉個念
立刻轉念
然後或者說立刻選擇
媽我不爽幹
我辭職或什麼的
你只要有選擇的東西
立刻股票去降槓
立刻去把本來
可能掉下來的東西
煎起來什麼的
你只要可以去
因為你的作為
就改變了事情
那個真的
不算什麼煩惱
特別是我覺得
很多地方爸媽
可能跟我一樣
那時候兒子
遇到一些事情
當你開始有這些
你沒有辦法做任何事情的東西出來之後你對世界的感受會變得很不一樣以前你曾经以为是很严重很大条的东西你后来就发现那根本就没什么
然后你也会理解像一些那种
很俗套的话
钱可以解决的
真的都不是问题
有很多东西是
你有再多钱
你有再多的意志力
好像以前我都是那种人定胜天的
我就会知道说
有些事情我没有办法解决
所以当面对这种事情的时候
最好的方式就像这两位
聽眾朋友們
我不知道他的太太是不是
反正總之就是稍微的去期待未來
因為也只能夠這樣
要知道其實每個人都會遇到一些不好的事情
好 最後面好事終將會發生
只能夠這樣
人是要維持樂觀的
維持樂觀才有藍料軍面對每一天
下面有位
領口太會吃飯
好人你幫幫人民的
為基金設立福利天主善的
後面那是我接的
你看這就是暗號
他前面講那個我後面是要接這個
還是有人懂GI Joe的
所有GI Joe的回憶都回來啦
看到很多人都有共同的回憶
讓我覺得這個同溫層超讚
那請夢工用川普的語氣做的好麻吉阿景
6月15號生日快樂
What a great guy this is
下面一位
smlo加碼一顆新當標題川普聲音
後面要祝我生日快樂
我只是不太習慣跟我自己講生日快樂
非常感謝大家的心意
那周四在Computex
收穫滿滿卻沒有遇到主委太遺憾了
那真希望可以跟MK當面交流業界的心得
那最後請夢工
右手向前做出彈額頭的手勢
湧唱酒缸偏光鳥語聲明
表裡之間虛勢齒
齒還在花
一個草下面一個齒
這是什麼奇怪的東西
該不會講了之後
待會我原地肛門爆炸之類的
這位兄弟好像你在AMD上班
沒記錯的話
因為我們在球場有遇到過
然後記得是他有跟我講
那是他的ID或什麼的
我現在看到AMD在漢萊
好像有一個施展
或許如果以後有酷東西的話
我也會想去看看
那一天是沒有看到AMD的東西
比較可惜沒有遇到
非常感謝你的祝福
那再念最後一個
最近在看剛練的EG
夢宮安安最近的人生問題是
不知道怎麼跟小六的子女說
不要太管閒事和太愛分享
因為有些小朋友不一定會想接受他的好意
那還想請夢宮用猛男語音
包住我的三位好朋友
北屯大寶娃
潘寶
風上蘋果汁
六月份生日快樂
那也順便請潘寶跟風上蘋果汁
趕快去玩火俠傳吧
感謝夢宮的呼籲
那真的是一款非常棒的遊戲
希望有一天可以在皮諾可可遇到您跟LISA
也祝福全家跟Choco健康快樂
非常感謝
我們祝他們生日快樂
也希望你們玩回到專案快樂
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕